il ya beaucoup de gens qui habitent ici
dans le xvième ya déjà des habitués des
habitués qui viennent depuis des années
c'est pour ça que nous connaissons à peu
près tous les chiens oui on par le chien
beaucoup et c'est très drôle parce que
nous appelons par les noms de chiens oui
ça s'appelle monsieur mois il s'appelle
pallada on appelle cela la wii pilou net
on m'appelle madame peloux net
elle s'appelle bisaillon m'appelle
madame kenza portée qu'elle s'appelle
tiburce à cause de lui tout le monde
m'appelle monsieur tiburce quick car
vous appelle madame quick
oui sociale lorsque vous arrivez
aujourd'hui pour jordan quick
oui si cela exactement tout le monde ici
était de nini on aime que les chiens
alors c'est tout à fait ça on va
assister par exemple à celui qui à son
chien sur le mode bouc émissaire sur le
mode de souffre douleur
c'est en général un individu qui lui
même a souffert dans son enfance son
adolescence de problèmes de l'on appelle
en jargon psychiatrique paranoid de
problèmes persécuteurs persécutés ou
agresseurs agressé qui a donc besoin de
vider une certaine masse d'énergie
agressive qui ne peut pas le faire
facilement sur un autre lui-même qui est
l'homme bien sûr car c'est entre lui
même se défend en général et alors il va
prendre un chien il prend un chien et il
le forment en quelque sorte comme
d'autres formes roth une femme et ce
petit sadisme garçon est faible
finalement cela qu'ils prennent un chien
ce petit sadisme
kylie qui va ce segment c'est sur le
chien fera que petit à petit le chien se
laissera ça disait si j'ose dire et
entrera dans une forme de masochisme
absolument semblable à celui que l'on
trouve au niveau des rapports d'homme à
femmes par exemple dans cet amour sado
masochistes car c'est un amour moi
j'aime mieux mon chien que certaines
personnes passent avec mon chien j'ai
jamais eu l'illusion la veille de marié
ma fille aînée j'ai éprouvé le besoin
d'avoir un siècle
comment on doit aimer les bêtes comme
soi-même comme la femme comme si la
france et pour les meilleurs
quelle est la place du chien auprès de
vous j'ai bien écouté ça attire
énormément de place et je crois que
maintenant je pourrais pas me séparer de
ses chiens est-ce que c'est un manque
affectif est ce que c'est pas du tout
non j'ai eu une sorte je suis marié non
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je vais
vous dire quand même une chose mais les
yeux c'est pour la télévision
je n'ai pas d'enfant est si vous voulez
en affection s'est reportée sur ses
chiens
voilà
[Musique]